ja seit dem Wochenende tobt eine neue
ukrainische gegen Offensive im Süden des
Landes in der Region herson und wir
wollen uns mal ansehen wie das etwa
aussieht wie dieser Gegenoffensive sich
nämlich bewegt es sind schneller
Einheiten der ukrainischen Armee es sind
Panzer es sind gepanzerte Fahrzeuge die
vorrücken entlang der Straßen und wir
sehen und hören vielleicht auch ein
bisschen das hier schon geschossen wird
aber man bleibt nicht einmal stehen ja
man bleibt also nicht stehen man muss
nicht kämpfen es gibt auch kaum Verluste
unter den ukrainischen Soldaten sondern
man bringt immer weiter vor und wir
sehen jetzt hier wurde gerade von einem
gepanzerten Fahrzeug von einem BTA 70
geschossen und da musste man mal kurz
stehen bleiben weil hier vorne ein
Minenfeld ist vielleicht sehen wir das
die Russen die zurück weißen Rosen haben
ja hier ein Minenfeld hinterlassen was
jetzt erstmal geräumt werden muss und
dann von den Ukrainern passiert werden
kann wir wollen uns das ganze auch
angucken aus den aus den befreiten
Städten hier aus veliker alexandrifka
ein relativ große Stadt mit ehemals 8000
Einwohnern eine von über 30 Städten die
hier befreit wurde wir sehen jetzt hier
wie ukrainische Soldaten ihre flag ein
bisschen auf dem Rathaus und sich
natürlich darüber freuen dass sie auch
diese Stadt zurückerobert haben wir sind
zwar hier eine ganze Menge Zerstörung
aber auch hier gab es keine direkten
Kämpfe bereits vier Stunden vorher haben
wir aus der gleichen Stadt Aufnahmen
gesehen von Anwohnern die gesagt haben
die Russen sind weg und genau das macht
das Ganze so ein bisschen trügerisch was
wir da sehen wir gucken uns das mal auf
der Karte an wir haben also hier die
Region Hassan und dieses riesige Gebiet
was hier in blau eingefärbt ist das war
noch bis zum Wochenende alles russisch
besetzt die Russen sind dort
zurückgezogen aber und das ist was
besonderes sie sind offenbar rechtzeitig
zurückgezogen sie haben sich nicht
einkesseln lassen von der Ukrainern sie
haben sich nicht ja abschießen lassen wo
den Ukrainern und sie haben ganz anders
als wir erinnern unseren tragiefe zum
Beispiel nicht hunderte Fahrzeuge
verloren sie haben einige Fahrzeuge
verloren wir sehen hier Fotos von alten
t-62 die haben wir vor einigen Wochen
vorgestellt das sind 60 Jahre alte
russische Kampfpanzer die jetzt als
Ersatz für den Ersatz sozusagen
geliefert wurden und im Süden eingesetzt
wurden davon sind fünf erobert worden
von der Ukrainern dazu etwa weitere fünf
gepanz Fahrzeuge aber das macht 10 und
das macht nicht die 350 Fahrzeuge die in
Raki beispielsweise in einer Woche
erobert wurden und insofern ist die
Frage tatsächlich ist das Ganze
nachhaltig ist Putin hier wirklich weg
die Russen sagen und in diesem Fall kann
man es ihnen fast glauben wir haben
unsere gruppiert wir sind zurückgegangen
aber wir sind mit allen Waffen gegangen
wir sind mit allen Soldaten gegangen wir
haben kaum Verluste und insofern ist es
möglich dass die Russen ja eine neue
schwere Kampflinie Vorbereiten von der
aus Sie die
verbleibenden besetzten Gebiete von
Carson auch verteidigen wollen wir
wollen jetzt mal wieder haben wir schon
länger nicht mehr gemacht ansehen mit
welcher westlichen Munition und zwar in
diesem Fall deutscher Munition Smart 155
heißt die die Ukrainer vorgehen und ganz
zielgerichtet hier russische Fahrzeuge
zerstören wir haben hier einen
russischen Schützenpanzer vom Typ BMP2
der versteckt sich und wir sehen jetzt
gleich einfach mal was da passiert denn
wir haben hier eine relativ starke
Explosion darauf und wir gucken mal
genau hin in der Zeitgruppe die
Explosion ist tatsächlich nicht direkt
auf dem Panzer sondern die findet hier
oben statt und das ist eine sogenannte
Smart 155 Munition die wird hergestellt
von einer Tochterfirma von Rheinmetall
und Deal und auch die wurde in die
Ukraine geliefert und das Besondere an
der ist die Sucht das Gebiet ab nach
Zielen also die Munition selber sucht
das Gebiet ab und wenn sie dein Ziel
gefunden hat dann wird zielgerichtet auf
dieses Ziel eine sogenannte gerichtete
Ladung gefeuert wir sehen uns das noch
einmal an die also über dem Ziel
abgeschossen wird und danach eben zu
einer ja zu einer Zerstörung des Zieles
führt obwohl es selber gar nicht
getroffen wurde sondern die Explosion
hier oben stattgefunden hat das also
etwas was die Ukraine einsetzt und zwar
nicht nur im Süden Landes Landes sondern
auch im Osten des Landes auch hier
wollen wir uns einmal ansehen was für
riesige Gebiete dort befreit wurden hier
oben wir haben eben darüber gesprochen
die Großoffensive in Raki vor etwa zwei
Wochen aber allein in den letzten Tagen
ist dieses gesamte Gebiet hier befreit
worden und auch das ist wirklich riesig
wenn wir sehen dass es sich um ungefähr
zehn Prozent 15 Prozent des gesamten
besetzen dann was handelt also auch hier
haben wir riesige ukrainische Vorstöße
die gehen weiter gehen jetzt Richtung
luanski oben weiter und insofern ist
dort noch einiges zu erwarten in den
nächsten Tagen und wir haben heute auch
gehört das weitere 4 Städte dort befreit
wurden das heißt die Ukrainer Rücken
weiter vor die Frage bleibt ist dieser
Vormarsch wirklich von Dauer und sind
die großen in der Lage irgendwann eine
neue Verteidigungslinie oder sogar mit
den 300.000 Mann die sie jetzt
mobilisiert haben eine neue gegen
Offensive gegen die Ukraine zu starten
[Musik]